this video is kindly sponsored by
conflict of nations the free online pvp
strategy game hey 42 here they say that
necessity is the mother of all invention
and never is there a greater need than
in times of war
that's why periods in history just have
seen large amounts of conflict have
traditionally catalyzed huge leaps
forward in technology
the first world war saw tanks trundle
onto the world's battlefields for the
first time
and the second world war saw the
invention of the jet engine as well as
the harnessing of nuclear power
this process began literally thousands
of years ago and it's still ongoing
today which is why the battlefields of
tomorrow will undoubtedly look very
different to the ones you and i grew up
learning about in history class
as of right now the world superpowers
are piling billions of dollars into a
new generation of military technology
that wouldn't look out of place in the
latest sci-fi blockbuster
i'm talking predator-style adaptive
camouflage hypersonic missiles that can
strike targets on the other side of the
globe in a matter of minutes
laser cannons that can slice projectiles
right out of the sky cyborg insects that
can infiltrate enemy encampments with
ease
and enhanced reality goggles that will
make fighting a war look like playing a
computer game
with futuristic technologies like these
appearing on the distant and in some
cases not so distant horizon
we humans will soon have to accept an
uncomfortable truth
we're starting to become the weak link
in warfare
and you can experience realistic modern
warfare in conflict of nations which
puts you at the heart of global modern
warfare allowing you to choose a real
country to lead in epic battles in a bid
to take over the world you fight with up
to 128 other players in real-time combat
that can take weeks to complete this
game will test your ability to manage
your units such as tanks jets attack
helicopters and submarines what i love
about this game is the importance of the
realistic in-game economy and how it
affects the long-term outcome of a war
you have to carefully choose when and
how to attack to maximize your chances
of victory it's also really handy that i
can sign into my account on both pc and
mobile meaning i can take the action
with me wherever i am so click the link
in the description to get an exclusive
gift thirteen thousand gold and one
month of premium subscription for free
the offer is only available for 30 days
so hurry
500 years ago the strength of a man's
arm was a huge factor in his prowess on
the battlefield
great warriors had the skill and
charisma to turn the tide of battle and
in some cases even decide entire wars
these days with our technology doing
pretty much all the killing the people
controlling it are turning into a bit of
an afterthought and in some cases even a
liability
we simply weren't built for war on a
modern scale
i mean think about it
we're relatively small fragile animals
trying to hold our own on battlefields
full of metal monsters capable of
unleashing casual destruction at the
push of a button or the pull of a train
and it isn't just our relative
squishiness that's the problem most
human beings perform pretty poorly in
high stress situations
the more pressure we're put under the
more likely we are to make mistakes we
get tired quickly meaning we need to be
unconscious and therefore defenseless
for large portions of every day in order
to remain effective
we need to eat and drink regularly or we
die and we're only able to operate in a
relatively narrow range of atmospheric
conditions and temperatures before we
just
shut down
we get sick fairly easily we die if you
dunk us into water for too long and we
turn into horrible little monsters if
you feed us after midnight
oh sorry that last one's gremlins isn't
it
anyway what i'm trying to say is this
as fantastic as our human militaries are
military technology grows more
proficient at annihilating enemies every
year making human soldiers increasingly
obsolete as a consequence
one way to circumvent this inherent
human fallibility is to just go full
technology and lets the machines wage
war for us
as scary as that may sound there's a
good chance it's already happening
a u.n security council report published
last year
appeared to suggest that anonymous ai
controlled drones took actual human
lives on the battlefields of libya in
2020 and that's almost certainly just
the thin end of the wedge
as ai continues to improve killer
machines could well become a military
mainstay
but there is one way to remove human
fallibility from the warfare equation
without actually removing the humans
one that's being explored by governments
all over the world right now
we can simply stop humans from being
fallible in the first place
from the wheel to the steam engine to
quantum computers technologies are tools
that we use to make our lives better
but our understanding of science is
reaching a point where we can begin to
consider not only how we can keep making
better tools
but how we can make ourselves better
tools
in 2018 chinese scientists heard zhang
kwai edited the dna in embryos of a set
of twins to make them less susceptible
to hiv
the experiment was incredibly
controversial for reasons i'll come on
to in a minute but it was also
incredibly significant when the twins
were born they became the first
gene-edited babies in history
and whilst making soldiers immune to hiv
probably wouldn't give them all that
much of an edge on the battlefield
there's no reason why we couldn't apply
the same cutting edge technology used by
juan kwai and his team to create other
more drastic modifications to the human
genome
modifications that could conceivably
pave the way for real-life super
soldiers
the embryos of juan qui's hiv-resistant
babies were modified using a technology
known as crispr
which acts like a kind of living
programmable piece of genetic software
that can hunt down a specific chunk of
dna
remove it and replace it with a new
custom sequence
this particular method of genome editing
was discovered by scientists emmanuel
charpentier and jennifer doudner earning
the pair the nobel prize for chemistry
in 2020
and there's a very good reason why the
research was honoured with science's
highest accolade
crispr could quite literally
change what it means to be human
for starters having the power to edit
our genes means we may one day be able
to all but eradicate a whole host of
diseases including cancer cystic
fibrosis and huntington's disease
among many others
and that may well just be the first step
on a much longer journey because
eventually
we may be able to use crispr not only to
eliminate undesirable genetic traits but
to actively enhance or introduce
desirable ones
so what would you do if you could bestow
any genetic gift you wanted upon your
children if you're a loving parent
perhaps you'd go for genes that would
make your child more intelligent or more
attractive or maybe you'd give them a
smattering of the recently identified
genes that have been linked to people
who earn higher incomes
but if you were a military leader
looking to gain an edge on the
battlefield
well
in theory your options would be limited
only by the potential of the human
genome itself to put that another way
you could design a human being that
could do anything within the genetic
capability
of our entire species think of it like
min maxing a character in a video game
except you're basically just max maxing
gene editing could be the key to faster
stronger more resilient humans with
enhanced intelligence and an increased
tolerance for pain
it could be a way to make soldiers bred
specifically for high altitude warfare
desert combat or covert operations
in other words real life super soldiers
of course there's one teeny tiny issue
of all of this gene editing in humans is
an ethical minefield
i mentioned earlier that hey zhang
quay's experiment to produce
hiv-resistant babies was controversial
but to tell the truth i was underselling
it a bit the experiment wasn't just a
little bit edgy
it was illegal juan quay wasn't just the
first person to create a genetically
modified human he was also the first
person to go to jail for it
editing the genes of human embryos is
banned pretty much everywhere on the
planet
and for good reason
messing around with the human genome is
akin to playing god
and it's safe to say that nobody alive
really has the required qualifications
for that particular job if we want to
improve our species through genetic
enhancement
who gets to decide what counts as an
improvement or which traits need
eliminating you don't have to be a
student of history to know that some
very very bad things have been done in
the name of one person's idea of genetic
superiority
but
crispr is a technology of such power
that we can't simply sweep it under the
scientific rug
much like research into atomic weapons
during the second world war gene editing
is going to happen no matter how bad it
might ultimately turn out to be for us
as a species
genetically modified soldiers could
change the face of war forever
allowing world superpowers to breed
elite armies that are tougher stronger
and cleverer than the enemy and let's
face it as a species we humans have
shown many times that we're willing to
pay any price for that kind of power
okay so it might sound like i'm getting
a bit carried away here
but there's very good reason to believe
that several of the world's most
powerful militaries
are already actively working on the
development of so-called super soldiers
according to former u.s director of
national intelligence john ratcliffe the
chinese have already reached the human
trial stage in their quest to develop
soldiers with biologically enhanced
capabilities
and as is so often the case when it
comes to military technology
when one nation starts an arms race is
triggered with everyone else jumping on
the bandwagon to avoid falling behind
no head of state wants to find
themselves in a situation where their
normal human soldiers are facing off
against 50 000 captain americas
last year french minister of the armed
forces florence pali confirmed plans to
kick off research into genetically
enhanced soldiers and whilst for obvious
reasons the details as to precisely
which other nations are doing exactly
what when it comes to gene editing
our fin on the ground
it's safe to say that every major
military power in the world is at the
very least exploring the implications
okay so does all this mean it's only a
matter of time before we start seeing
real-life supermen fighting our wars for
us
well
not necessarily crispr gives us the
power to edit the human genome with a
level of precision that would have
seemed practically impossible just a few
decades ago
but creating a genetically enhanced
super soldier isn't quite so simple as a
little dna cut and paste
the human genome contains around three
billion base pairs and the truth is we
quite literally have no idea what the
majority of it actually does
i mean we know it makes us human beings
but exactly which bits do what
what we do know is that most traits are
governed by complex relationships
between multiple different genes
so it isn't as simple as just finding
the muscles gene and replacing it with
the absolutely stacked gene
altering an individual's genetic code is
an incredibly complicated business
and with our current level of
understanding there's simply too big a
risk of making changes that have
unwanted side effects
and i'm not talking about the oh look
he's got superpowers kind of sound
effects more the
why isn't he breathing anymore kind
for the time being
gene editing means meddling with powers
we simply can't comprehend
there's a very good chance the
scientific challenges that stand between
us and real life super soldiers are
surmountable
as for how long that will take
well
it's hard to say for sure
but hey if you happen to spot a seven
foot military looking type with huge
muscles jogging down the street faster
than usain bolt while simultaneously
solving a sudoku
be sure to let me know
thanks for watching
and thanks again to conflict of nations
for sponsoring this video to help you
get on your road to taking over the
world i'm giving my viewers a special
gift if you click on the link below
you'll get 13 000 gold and one month of
premium subscription for free this offer
is only available for 30 days so don't
waste any time on your road to victory